hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich sitze immer wieder mit Sandra
hey die mich in Sims erstellt hat ich
weiß immer noch nicht wie du mich so
erstellen konntest ne also ohne Witz ich
finde ich habe Luca besser getroffen als
er mich zeig mal mich ganz kurz Teil
hier pack mal bitte im Schnitt uns beide
nebeneinander
einfach jetzt so mich auf die linke
Seite den auf die rechte Seite bis dann
Ähnlichkeit glaub nicht doch ich habe
auf jeden Fall auch noch Sandra erstellt
da seht ihr jetzt meine Vergleich
wie ein bisschen
Sandra und ich spielen heute endlich mal
wieder die Sims 4 es gab ein großes
besonderes Update das Säuglinge ins
Spiel gebracht hat und dazu ist auch das
neue Erweiterungspack die Sims 4
zusammenwachsen erschienen mit dem das
Gameplay noch vertieft wird das Pack
bringt außerdem Meilensteine für das
Leben der Sims vom ersten Lächeln bis
zum mitleidpreises und ganz neue
familiendynamiken und das Testen heute
zusammen
wir können jetzt hier oben neben
Kleinkinder nämlich auch auf Säuglinge
klicken
wollen wir denn direkt so nehmen warte
auf zufällig so ein bisschen
[Musik]
Manuel
wir brauchen so einen coolen Namen so
amerikanischer
[Musik]
was ist unser Nachname von unserem
Haushalt MCS Einstein
Familie Einstein
das heißt weil wir jetzt eine Familie
sind kann ich nicht mit anderen flirten
naja wir sind nicht verheiratet wir sind
nur Haushaltsmitglieder
wenigstens in Sims wenn ihr übrigens das
neue Erweiterungspack zusammenwachsen
spielen wollt benötige
selbstverständlich das kostenlose Basis
spielt die Sims 4 schon krank das ist
mittlerweile kostenlos ist also alle
unter euch die quasi mehr Interaktionen
und Features rund um das ganze Thema
säuglinge haben wollen
gönnt euch ich würde sagen wir ziehen im
Frühling ja Frühling ist eine schöne
Zeit wo ziehen wir hin nach Sanski ja du
hast es falsch ausgesprochen
der kommt nämlich mit dem
Erweiterungspack auch mit dazu guck mal
da bist sogar
sagen wir ziehen einfach mal hierhin
Palast am Park ist doch perfekt für
unser Schloss Einstein das stimmt
echt schön
Papa
drin was lese ich denn die 1% Methode
[Musik]
also wir müssen uns mal ein bisschen
hier konzentrieren auf MC yes der hier
draußen direkt mit Sandra so ein
bisschen am rumflirten ist oh guck mal
direkt plus.de gesammelt es kommt
tatsächlich
mit den Säuglingen kommen tatsächlich
ganz viele neue zwischenmenschliche
Dynamiken dazu guck mal ihr geht rein
ich finde es auch bei die Sims richtig
interessant einfach mal so zu beobachten
weißt du wir schauen jetzt mal denkst du
wie geht's zu mir
[Musik]
eine Küche nee du bringst du bringst sie
jetzt zum Wickeltisch
oh ich leg ihn auf dem Boden oder sind
Teppich gesprochen
tatsächlich auch Steuern und sagen jetzt
mal er soll ach nee er soll hier hin
getragen werden von mir ich habe jetzt
mal mich ausgewählt und jetzt kommt
wieso ist das Säugling gerade alleine MC
jetzt ich weiß wir sind schlecht Eltern
Luca trägt jetzt
MC yes in seinen Spieleparadies das
schon krass dass man damit so klingen
beschäftigen kann ne das Spiel jetzt
einfach da dran rum oder wie den einfach
dahin
ich reicht komplett aus füttern
Präferenz oh krass bevorzugt das Futter
mit der Flasche dann klicken wir jetzt
mal auf gefüttert werden von Sandra
Einstein mal schauen ob es anders Check
was macht Luca bei MCS der sollte da gar
nicht hin guck mal ich kann das
Verbessern ein Baby mobile hinzufügen
[Musik]
kommt genauso gut handwerklich wie ich
Kuchen
auf unsere Gäste und geht lieber zu Luca
der irgendwie nicht so ganz klar komm
mit dem Ding Aussehen
du musst
lieber mit der Flasche gefüttert werden
möchte wir schwul mal ein bisschen vor
und beobachten mal und schauen mal was
sie hier machen wenn wir den keine
Aufgaben geben Sandra geht rein und ich
du hast auch so heult
hey was bin ich denn für eine schlechte
Mutter guck mal jetzt so macht man das
gut oder
freut er sich ja guck mal plus
ja wahrscheinlich weil er mein Bizeps
angefasst
eingestellt wie auch in echt
so anstellen
Luca bringt jetzt MC jetzt erstmal in
die Badewanne
nämlich abstoßen also man kann jetzt
neuerdings auch ein Baumhaus bauen
sondern Säugling das Problem ist
allerdings
ja wir haben viel zu kleines Grundstück
MCS irgend eines Tages kriegst du dein
Baumhaus ich bin dafür dass wir jetzt
einen Ausflug machen schau mal ob wir
vielleicht irgendwas im Dorf finden was
uns Spaß machen könnte oh ja ich komme
morgen gelaufen
da kommt Sandy und läuft zu unserem
Ausflug hier hin zum splashpad und da
kommt Luca und läuft
eine Frage unser fragt er sich was das
ist deine Mama MCS halt's Maul ich merke
aber schon ganz genau dass die Sandra
erstmal hier ein Dickerchen machen will
komm rüber
[Musik]
und erstmal
ein bisschen relaxen ne der telefoniert
gerade
zu MCS da ich schlafe erstmal
pennt Sandra pennt und ich sterbe war
daneben und schau mir den Lachs an der
liegt auch voll im Wasser hier unten ne
gut mein Fehler
ist das nicht unser Kind
gar kein Problem überhaupt keinen Film
ne so ja und jetzt gib mir mal nee er
stinkt immer noch Luca er stinkt immer
noch hä aber ich habe ihn noch
gewechselt oder
er heult immer rum wenn er bei dir ist
es geht doch MC jetzt im Schaumbad Baden
ja das glaube ich ganz gut
[Musik]
man wirklich ein echtes Säugling zu
Hause hätte die Aufgabe muss man auch
machen wie viele Sachen du einfach
mittlerweile in Die Sims machen kannst
ist ja nicht ohne Grund eine der
bekanntesten PC Spielereien aller Zeiten
Handy
schon seit 22 Jahren
oder also ich bade hier MC jetzt auf
jeden Fall noch ein bisschen sandra ist
äh
[Musik]
m boah boah
schön ne aber das ist ein Gewächshaus ne
schön hier auch so denk mir er ist geil
die neue Map
oha
Alter was haben die da vorne Digger was
für ein schönes Haus hier wohnen ja nur
ritche Leute was ist das hier und dann
wir das soll so
mäßig sein
wird gefüttert hey wie ich mich hier
kümmere um das Dinge und ich fühle mich
unwohl ich Hunger habe Sandra kochen und
Festmahl und zwar ein Truthahn glaube
ich und während seiner das kocht meine
Damen und Herren würden wir dann glaube
ich das heutige Video auch beenden wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann lasst gern
einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier
da abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke weitere Videos nicht zu
verpassen wollt ihr weitere die Sims 4
Videos mit seiner mir dann schreibt uns
gerne mal unten in die Kommentare wie
bereits gesagt das neue Erweiterungspack
du hast es hingekriegt oh das sieht
immer so geil aus finde ich sondern
Kartoffelpüree und Gemüse
zusammen wachsen ist jetzt verfügbar
check mal gern die Infobox ab für
weitere Informationen das Basisspiel
braucht ihr natürlich dafür das ist
allerdings kostenlos die Sims 4 ladet
euch gerne mal runter ich kenne keine
Spielerei die wirklich so viele
Erweiterungen anbietet so viele
unzählige Möglichkeiten wir haben jetzt
gar nicht mehr erlaubt benutzen muss
halt unendlich äh Geld und
Kaufmöglichkeiten aber gut ähm auf jeden
Fall Nickerchen hier der kleine ähm und
wir beiden Essen jetzt unseren Truthahn
und ich gucke dabei Fernsehen und du
passt schon aufgegessen okay Leute haut
rein wir sehen uns macht's gut ciao ciao
ciao was war das denn
guck mal wie
was ist das wie ich auch gucke
du redest irgendwann von Flugzeugen oh
Gott jetzt schon aufgegessen Müll
hey was sind wir